what did you come out here for cuz
unless you figure that out no matter
where you go you're gonna be chasing
ghosts min and that's the fat
you're gonna be chasing ghosts cuz if
you don't know what's driving you inside
to get you through things then you're
not gonna figure out want to know
what passion is passion is losing things
it's hurt it's ache it's not knowing
when you wake up in the morning how
you're going to go to sleep and in what
condition that's passion passion is what
happens when nothing is happening when
you sit around and wonder why nothing is
happening why nothing is happening for
you why people are leaving you that's
your passion you can quit and you can
walk back and you can say I gave it my
all I gave it my seven years but the
passion will still be down there so deep
and you'll feel it every day and you
wonder why did I walk away 17 years plus
one day I could have had it
but you won't have it cuz you look
and that's your decision so you can walk
buddy
and I love you and your grid after but
you can walk